I don't know if I just understand the song wrong,
but when I hear Pink Pony Club,
I'm a mom. I'm 41.
Chapel Roan could actually be my daughter.
Like, if I got pregnant in high school really young,
and I was, like,
a teen mom, someone her age could maybe be my daughter.
I would be a young mom. You know what I mean?
That would be crazy. But either way,
when I see her, I love her music.
And when I see her, like,
I'm so hopeful that, like,
maybe my daughter could be,
you know, reach her goals.
Like, she just gives me hope for my children.
Like, I no longer see people like that and think for myself.
I think for my kids. So I love her.
When I listen to her music,
I'm listening with, like,
a mother's ear. If it was, like,
my daughter singing those words,
like, I would be,
you know, out of this world.
If my daughter. I'm proud of my kids.
When I hear punk Pink Pony Club,
I'm so. There's times where I sing that song and I fucking cry.
The way she says, um.
With the mom's response in the song,
like, so happy for her.
She's singing at the Pink Pony Club.
That's what she wanted to do.
She's so happy she made it to LA.
And her mom is like, oh,
what have you done, girl?
And it makes me sad. And then when I sing The song.
I sing it like, because that's how I was singing the song originally.
I would sing along to the song like if the mom was happy.
And then I was like, but these words don't really sound as happy as
I feel like you would be if your daughter, like,
she made it to LA. She's singing,
she's having fun, she's got friends.
What's wrong here? And then I realize,
oh, okay, okay,
okay, okay, okay.
Got it.
And maybe I don't understand the song.
I don't know.
I do also just cry a lot, but whatever.